so most interesting idea I've heard was
in a conversation with JPM Rangaswamy of
Salesforce about WikiLeaks and JP said
it's not the information that's
symmetric that matters if both the
public and the government or the public
and the company knows that it's just
public and it's not the information
that's uncorroborated that matters
because that's just a rumor the big
change that WikiLeaks and other linking
operations like Palestine papers and
open leaks really brings into the
environment he's a rising the amount of
information that's both asymmetric and
corroborated which is to say it used to
be only the government that do it now
the public knows it as well and it isn't
just a rumor we have the original source
and that's the that's the big change in
the leaking moment and that made a that
made a light bulb go off